[Music]
49 Sully Sully where are you
[Music]
no one warned us
no one said you were going to lose both
engines at a lower altitude than any jet
in history this was dual engine loss at
2,800 feet followed by an immediate
water landing with 155 souls on board
no one has ever trained for an incident
like that our job is to investigate how
a plane ended up in the Hudson River
it's not a crash was a forced water
landing simulation showed that you can
make it back to the airport not possible
I felt it go
why are gonna have bureaucrats I'm gonna
know I did the best I could of course
you did she saved everyone people call
you a hero I don't feel like there's
been too much talking the press already
overwhelmed by all this attention the
left engine was still operating and in
dentistry we find dangered the lives of
all those passengers I got an a320
diving for the ribbon you did everything
you could have was more than enough
bones the last drink kept my sober and
he had any troubles at home
this is the captain brace for impact
that plane
over 40 years in the air but in the end
I'm going to be judged on 208 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
I need to do something substantial in
order to get the attention of the club
why because they're exclusive and fun to
a better life
[Music]
people want to go on the internet and
check out their friends so why not build
a website that offers that friends
pictures profiles I'm talking about
taking the entire social experience of
college and putting it online so I've
got 2,200 hits within two hours thousand
22,000 this idea is a potentially worth
millions of dollars millions install our
website they're saying we stole the
Facebook I know what it says so did we
building behind faster than any of us
never sued him in federal court
I can't wait to stand over your shoulder
in what you rises if you guys are the
inventors of Facebook that the Facebook
is there anything that you need to tell
me your actions gonna permanently
destroyed everything I've been working
read
[Music]
you're being accused of intentionally
breaching security violating copyrights
privacy
[Music]
for six hundred million dollars as for
the charges I believe I deserve some
recognition from this board I'm sorry
yes I don't understand which part I met
my father for the first time when I was
28 years old when I had children my
children were gonna know who their
father was Chris Gardner was doing his
best we don't need to you don't need one
maybe next quarter it's possible but is
fast wait wasn't enough man I got two
questions for you what do you do and how
do you do it I'm a stockbroker
stockbroker oh hang on to my car for the
weekend but I need it back for Monday
feed the meter I need the rest I can't
wait anymore
I need you out of here in the morning
you gotta trust me all right I guess you
cuz I'm getting a better job yeah you
see if I can find you an application for
our internship mom left because of mom
and you didn't have anything to do with
that
there's no salary no I was not aware of
that my circumstances to change
something I don't know
last year we had an interns for a 90
percent on the written exam he wasn't
chosen it's not a simple pass back he's
not quitting on the [ __ ] are you don't
ever let somebody tell you you can't do
something
not even me alright alright
the night Bush where this is your pretty
internship at Dean Witter
he said you're smart this is impossible
I can do it
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a dream you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can do it
we want something go get it period I
want to show you something this
Rembrandt here you can come from all
over the world to see this yeah he's
good yeah
it's a fake that's impossible
people believe what they want to believe
the guy who made this was so good that
is real to everybody
notice the master the painting
[Music]
[Music]
toast to a new era
[Music]
never took a quarter from a phone booth
you stole I just got bigger boss
[Music]
it's war we're not winning it you speak
a word of what I'm about to show you you
will be executed for high treason it's
beautiful
it's the greatest encryption device in
history and the Germans use it for all
communications everyone thinks enigma is
unbreakable let me try and we'll know
for sure mr. Turing do you know how many
died because of it edit three while
we've been having this conversation
gentlemen meet mr. Turing we work
together then I'm afraid these men would
only slow me down popular at school way
short on staff we get more staffing you
have six minutes to complete the task
it's nearly impossible
no takes me 18 minutes and we're going
to break an unbreakable Nazi code and
win the war you need to pull off this
irascible genius routine one actually
has to be a genius
I'm designing a machine that will allow
us to break every message every day
instantly we're going to need all the
help you can get and they are not going
to help you if they do not like you have
you decrypted a single German message
you will never understand the importance
of what I am creating here our patience
has expired
Oh if you fire well then you'll have to
fire me me too and me better bloody well
Alan you do not have to do this alone
what's going on maybe things that one of
us is a Soviet spy
you've got more secrets to the best of
them what if I don't answer but in that
way don't tell anyone no it's illegal
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes they're just people who no one
imagines anything
[Music]
[Music]
I want to ask you what part of the
country you come from originate from
Canada I guess where that is well I know
where Canada is I've been there myself
well traveled for slave Solomon Northup
is an expert player on the violin I was
born a free man lived with my family in
New York be good for your mother until
the day I was to see to Solomon kidnap
sold into slavery I'm a free man and you
have no right whatsoever to detain me
you know free man you nut butter Georgia
run away we're down to the river Jordan
let's servant don't obey is Lord shall
be beaten with many stripes that's
Scripture the condition of your laborers
it's all wrong am i property you say
that with pride I say it is fact rank
man does how he pleases with his
property you come here days ago I was
with my family in my home now you tell
me all this loss if you want to survive
do and say as little as possible
dog you knowed something I did as
instructed there's something wrong it's
wrong with the instruction master bought
you here to work anymore or learn you
100 lashes I know what it like to be the
object of masters master in his own time
good luck tomorrow I'm not falling to
despair
I will keep myself on it tough sweet on
this opportunity
what was free man
I'm not a speck
[Music]
there are rich teams and there are poor
teams then there's 50 feet of crap and
then there's up welcome to old face my
jobs take this team to a championship I
need more money we're not in New York
we're not gonna compete with 120 million
dollar payroll you got to think dude
your goal shouldn't be to buy players
your goal should be to buy wins who are
you here is 25 players that have been
overlooked by every other team for one
reason or another
like an island of misfit toys in here
he's a championship team one that we
can't afford
who's the good the kid is the new
assistant GM we're gonna shake things up
tell them to want me to speak when I
point you yet the new direction of the
open eggs we are card counters at the
blackjack table we're gonna turn the
odds on the casino
you don't put a team together with a
computer Billy adapt to die Billy Beane
has come in and tried to reinvent the
system now it's just not working out
they call it Moneyball
I think that he bought a ticket on the
Titanic hey daddy
easy Google is your job what oh I go on
the internet sometimes well don't go on
internet watch TV talk to people do you
believe in this thing or not I don't %
listen up you may not look like a
winning team but you are one so play
like one tonight we're doing something
really unexpected and special and the
whole city is feeling it if we win this
team which is a game for good
it was better work I'm just kidding here
I am with a ninth generation medicine
man and what do I want to ask him about
getting closer to God
nope I want to discuss my relationship
since I was 15 you are in so much
trouble breaking up with a guy I haven't
had so much as two weeks just to deal
with myself you want to go away for a
year I used to have this appetite for my
life and it is just gone I want to go
someplace where I can marvel at
something I'm going to Italy India and
I'm going to end the year in Bali I love
you I'm having a relationship with my
pizza this is my no carb Left Behind
experiment I'm going for it
why did you come here I wanted to find
my balance you want to get to the castle
you got this one the moat why do you
always talk in front of our sticker
every day we have no sex for a long time
baby I pray for you
[Music]
I have the perfect man for you I am so
sick of people telling me I need a man
you don't need a man lose a champion
life's changing it's not a bad thing my
son could dance to complain about
I'm starving where should we go we
should go to the best restaurant in
tunnel of course my ways subtle Russian
spy satellite taking pictures and God
knows what get us up there Harrison we
can't justify a space program that
doesn't put anything in space we all go
end up unemployed riding around in this
pilot jump you're welcome to all 216
miles sit in the back of the bus we're
putting a human in the space we bring
him in too soon he burns up on reentry I
need math that doesn't yet exist find a
mathematician before the Russians plant
a flag on the Daniel you have
identification on I had no idea they
heard what a few women working in space
program space history needs a computer
yeah there's the gal for that she can
handle winning numbers you put in boom I
never had a color in here but don't
embarrass me this was an empty last
night I'm a negro woman I'm not gonna
entertain the impossible I'm standing
beneath a spaceship we are living the
impossible we have know how to program
Didache that's John Glenn what do you
ladies do for NASA calculate your
trajectory so I can't get anywhere
without the numbers how could it be
other than these white men it's equal
rights I have the right to say that in
Africa NASA doesn't commission females
for the engineer program every time we
have a chance to get ahead
I would like to attend today's briefing
there is no protocol for women attending
they move the finish line it all should
be thankful you have jobs it up
I don't even know if I can keep up in
that room you're better with the numbers
than anyone in that cabinet you've been
gone for 300 hours don't like it to me
to where I need you to be where the hell
do you go every day the colored bathroom
is a mile away we all get to the peak
together we don't get there at all 50
million people are watching this long
John the IBM strong let's get the girls
to check the knowledge my gals are ready
we can do the workout gurgling it's good
to know NASA hasn't given up on girl
fashion brain time the friendship seven
has experienced some sort of a
malfunction there's a little fireball
outside just get a little hot here
[Music]
friendship seven do you copy over think
after three years you can call me Mike
actually going into the office this
article was about saving young people's
lives you said write it up I said write
it up not make it up I did the best with
what I had you have a future ahead of
you Mike but not here
you know to be honest I'm relieved it's
over with the times he turned into a
real prick working for them hello I am a
reporter with The Oregonian I wanted to
get your side on the Christian Longo
story who he murdered his entire family
why are you telling me this because when
they have we handed him he said he was
Mike Finkel of the New York Times did he
say anything at all about why he claimed
to be me I hoped you might be able to
tell me that he was just a regular guy
an intelligent sane man he comes home
one night and kills his wife and kids it
makes no sense
thank you for seeing me mr. long call me
Chris so why me I've followed your whole
career I guess I felt like I knew you I
want to tell you my side of this only
maybe at this point it doesn't matter
she was always matters it always seems
to matter to you
this is the once-in-a-lifetime story
don't you see this has a second change
her an outcast that's not the man I
wanted to be none of us is the man he
wants to be hello Jill hey nice to meet
you grace
the Mike he's been a real friend to me I
just hope that we can be friends Tim I
believe we're dealing with an
exceptionally dangerous man a choice of
so many stories to tell and you chose
his actually he picked me didn't pick
you
he used you we think he's part of some
bigger game plan this isn't just about
me who do you have to protect
[Music]
and say you think he's innocent don't
you my whole reputation is on the water
don't give up on me are you really gonna
be the man who might set him free Chris
did you do with your kids to do
[Music]